[Music]
the red planet Earth's neighbor and the
destination of NASA's most ambitious
mission to date but this expedition will
be harder than we ever thought possible
it hurts to think of how hard it is at
the farthest a human being has ever been
from the earth we got to take every
precaution as NASA's astronauts arrive
at Mars they'll face a huge obstacle
landing on the planet is a daunting task
in the past Mars hasn't always rolled
out the welcome mat Mars is kind of like
a graveyard for spacecraft it's actually
really hard to send something from Earth
and land it on Mars this is how the
European Space Agency hoped its
$250,000,000 skia Pirelli Lander would
touchdown in 2016 but the Landers
system's got it wrong
the parachute detached early sending the
craft into freefall for 33 seconds
skia Pirelli smashed into the surface at
335 miles an hour leaving a deep black
scar on the Martian landscape it turns
out that Mars is actually a particularly
difficult planet to land on even
humanity's most brilliant engineers
we've got about a 50% success rate when
it comes to landing on Mars the red
planet is littered with dead spacecraft
that didn't stick the landing and for
NASA's first crewed - sent to Mars
the space agency must learn from these
mistakes but as the crew hurdles toward
the surface they're battling the same
problem as all the Landers that failed
before
the Martian atmosphere is 100 times
thinner than Earth's so it can't provide
the drag needed to slow a spacecraft
down so it's not like the earth where
you can have these big giant parachutes
that gently glide you down to the
surface you can use some of the air but
it's hard the Red Planet's thin
atmosphere is a problem that's been
billions of years in the making
Mars doesn't have a large atmosphere
because it's constantly being peeled
away due to the lack of protection of a
magnetic field the solar wind can strip
away an atmosphere on earth a liquid
metal core creates a magnetic field
which shields the planet and helps
maintain the atmosphere Mars is
different 4.5 billion years ago Mars and
Earth
formed from dust and gas in space
Mars forms we're building materials were
scarce its growth was stunted so Mars is
much smaller than the earth it's a
factor of 10 smaller than the earth and
that factor of 10 in mass is important
all of that extra mass allows the inside
of the earth to stay warm and to have a
core that's rotating which generates a
magnetic field 4 billion years ago the
churning heart of Mars started to cool
and solidify with no hot core there's no
magnetic field being generated all of
the high velocity charge particles
coming from the Sun pick away at the
atmosphere and slowly tear it away
we know it's losing atmosphere every
second due to the solar wind so you know
bye-bye atmosphere
with little Martian atmosphere to work
with NASA had to be creative to get it
screwless Landers to the Martian surface
in 2012 the Revolutionary sky crane
landed the Curiosity rover using
parachutes and retrorockets previous
missions have used both a parachute and
something else like a bouncy ball
inflated around the spacecraft I don't
think a human crew is gonna be too
pleased if they're going to be bouncing
under the surface and an airbag rolling
to a stop right to land people on Mars
NASA will need some new tricks the 2020
Rover will overcome the challenge with
the advanced supersonic parachute
inflation research experiment aspire
it will rapidly slow down the craft
with the force of an airplane jet engine
[Music]
this is fine for the rover it's actually
going to work no problem but it's not
going to work for people
a human Lander will weigh far more than
the two thousand three hundred pound
Rover not even supersonic parachutes
could land two crews safely on Mars NASA
will need a new plan one idea is to use
the thin Martian atmosphere in a unique
way there's an idea of coming in really
fast getting to the thick part of the
atmosphere and then going horizontal to
the ground and gliding and losing your
momentum that way
[Music]
as the astronauts descend they tilt the
nose of the Lander towards the Martian
surface aiming for the thickest part of
the atmosphere close to the ground then
they pull up at the last second using
friction from the atmosphere to slow the
crowd
descent engines switch on for the final
touchdown
is this a crazy idea I mean yeah it's
it's a little bit weird I don't know if
we'd really think about it
doing something like this but I mean
you've got to think outside the box
sometimes right now NASA's plans for
landing a craft on Mars are still on the
drawing board but even if they can get
astronauts on to the surface the thin
atmosphere isn't done with them yet
it causes swirling dust storms that
cover the planet's entire surface
Mars doesn't just have dust devils it
has dust hill and these towering clouds
have killed before